der ndr banks kopf das wird nicht billig
crandall you're strange at times
du bist hier ist ein rocker banks kopf
am ende ist es doktor wenn's passt mal
auf
wir machen aus cats crandall der spieler
ist es doch ganz einfach in der runde
das ist nämlich seinen kopf und der name
ist da wo etwas dicker als option seien
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
mit roberto karten gab magath capristo
bestätigte
anstatt dass wir wenn wir als team schon
mal neben anders pauli immer genau
genommen den tun irgendeiner irgendwo
marten verachtenswert richtig alter und
wenn du doch er hat dass sie schon meine
habt macht dich da ist es gut dass wir
noch zusammen holen was los was hat er
alles hinter uns jahrelang dafür langt
kommt so alt er hat nicht mit so jungen
juni um ihm am kopf
ich bin hätte ich bin dass sie in ihrem
stichmann ich bin da für dich
weißt du das nicht was ist das für ein
fisch kommt keine ahnung was ich puste
die findigkeit vertrag als cooler ist
wie immer so
drei habe ich verloren also ich hab den
hat den meist nimmt dem schwert jagst
alles kleiner pisser kombi kam ein
jammer wenn ich über verfolger da bin
ich dir noch tüten mal hebt wie im ohne
witz und wenn es das letzte ist was du
tust
im alter junge war meister basel
geflogen was ja irgendwie habe ich so
eine fähigkeit die leute immer so
richtig in die luft zu heben
natürlich kleine chance in die toilette
zu heben ja der geist ist klar wollen
wir leute ich bin alles normal oder ich
bin mal wieder als rapper genau der
kommissar
meine maus alles klar gemacht ich mache
das aber nicht freiwillig passt kurz auf
ich hab vor allem aus glaube ich habe
keine mauspad ich habe immer noch max im
verdacht das ehrlich sagt jedes mal aber
ja ich hab echt im slum sensor ich bin
ja monat leute der struggle israel das
sortiment war oh lieber nicht passieren
stellt euch mal vor
bitteres wäre dadurch mit absicht
ist die hand ausgerutscht finde ich die
extra für ware frisch sei
denkst du kannst du mit schuhkauf längst
bin so eine [ __ ] nrw ja ganz ehrlich da
passt so gut hier
bitte sag nicht ich hab das extra
geändert
es hat mit kleinstem raum ist offenbar
jetzt jemand hier ist ja wo ist da die
roma zum bogen vielleicht sollte ich ja
aber das ist ein scheiß der raum zu
kämpfen hier heraus sagt man nicht erst
alle reden so schlau wie bei weinproben
alias plodden typ kirche jeden bereich
der abriss der typ weil es gibt sie zwar
für den ihr witz es gibt jetzt es gibt
jetzt die combo junge da ist monat und
zwar jetzt
da war einfach dinge als ist ein ding
ning es ist kein krieg
minecraft pro hd maike das mich schon
pro team
sie sollten nämlich als die hat alles
für sein team weg gegeben hatte
was die macher tolerant dankeschön das
hinterrad machst sonst hätten wir ja
immer diese fähigkeit irgendwie sie gut
zu sein und schön zu sein
seine kampfkraft steigt immer weiter an
um ein grad junge ins oberhaus
daher kommt das opern 1000 von
dragonball rené bruder von die manchmal
klappt und was weiß ich dann halte ich
das immer schlauer
jedes mal wieder weinproben regel
wirklich so schlau wir haben 99 prozent
des inhalts ist auf alkohol hätte ich
nicht gedacht
was denkst du alles oder nichts
geschehen konzentriert schön zu hause
bild destilliert
aber nicht sogar das equipment so hinter
mir ja bruder erwarte ich muss erst
wieder wenn ich kann heute seine worte
ist wie gesagt wir das gleiche fahrzeug
bietet geht man solidarität den anderen
ich hab den ja ich hab den ich habe den
haben komm komm ich hab nur so hätten
damals gegenseitig geld hin ein
ich hab ich nicht hätte du legst
irgendwelchen viel mehr schaden hat sich
erkämpfen
damit erkennt jetzt hier und wo es hakt
an den online faktisches geringern kein
ding noch zwei gegner der einer
tochterbank skoff das bin ich das billig
crandall new strain top mannschaft
du bist hier ist ein ra banks kopf am
ende ist es doktor wenn's passt mal auf
die macher stats crandall der spieler
ist es dr banks einfach in der runde
das ist nämlich seinen kopf und der name
ist da wo etwas dicker als ob mir
gefällt sind denn was ich unsere
aufnahme von nutzen sein alter für die
hilfe kann junge was diesen besitz alter
als ob paß auf es gibt so ein held im
deathmatch alter ohne wird sich macht
ihn so fertig ohne witz alter ja doktor
banks als hetze als westen wenn ich nach
geträumt richtig ernst hätte es zu
diesem thema wir sind gar nicht abgehört
und west mit nachgedacht viele schuldner
ist da bildung müsse daran gedacht was
wir haben die waren auch voll verplant
irgendwie ja wir hatten ich hab das gar
nicht
ja wie lange ist nicht zu helfen dem
moment zwar so eine geile runde alter
egal aber jetzt immer noch keinen neuen
pc ist ich bin immer noch ich bin
einfach immer noch behoben
das habe sie nicht leben man geht von
herzen
man lächelt echt gekämpft oder missionen
zu fördern
ärgerlich erst mal auf der emmer damit
dass er noch guten team haben sagt gm
opel stellen halbherzig schade schade da
sie ja dann macht er es auch einen
entfall der mit seiner danke für die
aufnahme kreis übrigens geknackt und
welchen wenn es nämlich eine aufnahme
knecht das ist wenn es aber das hat das
habe ich gut entschlüsselten habe ich
bin entschlossen so das was morgigen
video kann der beschreibung fängt alles
klar machen und schauen das leid tue